my name is Gary Hardin I'm running for
president how much is the public
entitled to know about a politician's
personal life and ultimately who gets to
decide these are the questions at the
heart of the new film the front-runner
the film is based on the true story of
Senator Gary Hart's run for the 1988
Democratic presidential nomination a
campaign that derailed after the Miami
Herald reported allegations that Hart
was having an affair with model Donna
rice directed by Jason Reitman who
co-wrote the screenplay with reporter
Matt Buy and foreign political operative
Jake Carson the film tells the story of
hearts doomed campaign to the eyes of
his family campaign aides and a press
corps wrestling with the idea of what is
newsworthy senator won't ask you some
questions about the woman in your
townhouse can you tell us how you know
her you can't be serious no one is thing
in my home there's no need for that I am
serious sir
I couldn't quite believe there was this
moment in our recent history when the
presumed next president of the United
States wound up in an alleyway mill and
night behind his home with some other
journalists no one knew what to do
because no one had ever been there
before I mean it just sounded like a
movie it was a thriller why are we
standing in an alley on a Saturday night
I mean don't you think you owe it to us
to be for us oh you you're denying what
we've seen with our own the only thing I
deny is the idea that somehow you have
the right to ask me do you think you're
running for president I'm aware of that
tom it's in the paper a responsibility -
Juan's abilities are judo yours it had
all this connective tissue with today
all these questions about our public
live versus our private lives gender
politics our relationship with
journalism and what we want to know
about our potential leaders what flaws
were willing to put up with and our
leaders and there's something about this
moment in 1987 where we suddenly showed
a very deep interest in Gary Hart not
only as a politician not only as someone
with ideas but someone as a flawed human
being who had made a mistake we wanted
to know more about that mistake we've
come to impor where we live in a culture
that kind of revolves around shame in an
interesting way and if you are someone
who experiences shame you drop out of
the race but if
you're someone who doesn't experience
shame not only do you stay in but you
thrive so you're onto the process
exactly so the process so it is a
process that that really supports the
shameless but in this story we don't
have good guys and bad guys we're not
placing blame on any of the people in
there we're trying to show human beings
who are faced with difficult choices and
are doing the best they can in those
circumstances that no one had ever faced
before and so we literally try to show
the journalists as humans the candidate
is human the operatives is human like I
got a hundred kids unpacking boxes in
Denver right now because we told them
you would do what it takes to win this
thing I told them people are sacrificing
for you and I'm not sacrificing what
should I sacrifice my privacy bill my
self-respect hmm then it won't just be
me that gets dragged down none of those
kids you're talking about will work
another campaign or some candidate
doesn't have to account for who comes
and goes from their bedroom and that is
just the beginning okay okay but we're
not we're not talking about that right I
am talking about down we're talking
about how you get through today without
pissing away everything we've all worked
for on this campaign bill this campaign
is about the future not rumors not
sleaze and I care about the sanctity of
this process whether you do or do not
but between the two of us we spent over
40 years in politics and and the broken
system broke broke us and so you know we
came to this this process has been
somewhat cathartic and I fine I feel a
good bit of catharsis every time I watch
the movie I've seen it over a dozen
times now because you know we're
exploring we're exploring some of the
story of how it got so messed up it's
funny because I have a similar
experience and I watch it I think could
that be me could I be in the alley
could I be where Tom's readers could I
be could I would I've said in that post
meeting and I never find a really
satisfactory answer to that the answer
is never of course not I wouldn't do
that and that that's not realistic and
and so you're always you know to me it's
uh it's it's you can watch it
differently and come away with a
different perspective every time yeah I
see this I see the operatives doing
stuff that I used to do and think oh
that's no big deal and I see it on the
screen and I go
looks that what's really unattractive I
can't believe I used to do that every
day right men's earlier work also
resisted passing judgment on his
characters in an interview about his
critically acclaimed 2007 film Juno
which tackles teenage pregnancy reitman
said I'm not really pro-choice I'm not
really pro-life and libertarian and I
think people should make decisions for
themselves in his 2005 film thank you
for smoking which delves into the
alliance between politicians and big
business reitman doesn't condemn
cigarette use as he told the arizona
republic' at the time quote as a
libertarian I don't like government
control people should be left to their
own devices
I mean you self-described in the past as
sort of a libertarian with a heart with
a certain political views with that sort
of worldview I wonder what sort of
discussions you guys had about this well
you're hashing out the scripted story I
mean I'm like anyone I look around and I
wonder how that all we got here the the
conversation is so shrill you go on
Twitter and you just see people tearing
each other apart so I'm I am desperately
in search of a reasonable conversation I
think our discussion it was as we were
all writing this sort of iterative
process it was never about there's never
an argument over the animating questions
or how we felt it was more it was more
is that is that real is that authentic
is that the way it would really be you
know and and is it complex the
complicated part about making the movie
in 2018 is making sure that everyone has
an access point to the story because you
know it's it's not as much a movie about
Gary Hart as much as it is a movie about
a group of people trying to understand
Gary Hart you know and the first half
the film specifically cinematically
follows over a dozen people at the
Washington Post at the Herald on his
campaign staff in his family men women
young old veterans newcomers each trying
to understand an enigma of a human being
who is not self-aware himself and and we
kind of knew that all right each one of
these characters were following is gonna
give us an access point and and and it's
someone's we have to stretch that a
little you know like end of ROI you know
an editor at The Washington Post we gave
her
more language from 2018 when it comes to
the women's movement because that is
part of this conversation and at that
point while it is important for us to be
accurate to 1987 it is more important
for people now to be able to watch this
film and feel as though they hear that
voice within the argument and they can
watch it ping-pong off of the other
voices within the film it's this isn't a
movie
I think people who should or will walk
out of going now I've got the answer you
know but but it is it is hopefully a
movie where people walk out saying and
we've seen this in some of the initial
you know screenings as people walk
outside I think he was wrong I think he
was right you know I mean you you you
know those are great experiences we've
all had the experience of leaving with
your you know your your wife or your
friend or whoever and you and you're in
the car arguing about what the movie was
really about who is who was at fault
what the decisions made that we're
critical I think that's what that's what
were going for here is to is to let
people think for themselves
you